he's my ink to my yang so he's my safe
zone he's
the one i trust the most admired the
most uh he's the one that makes me
laugh
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this episode is very very
special we already met with amit the ceo
of compete but now we're going to hear a
different story about the company the
story of her and her husband yoni who's
the cto of the company this is going to
be a very special one so stay tuned
welcome amit and yoni
[Applause]
co-founders of compete a an incredible
company coming out of israel
looking at you know the world of talent
and and i and i think we can all agree
that there is no talent problem there is
no shortage everybody's just happy uh
so no but compete as you know in 2022
this is all we can hear about and so
it's incredibly relevant
very fast growing company you have some
incredible customers already on board
and most interestingly in the company
you the two of your co-founders and
you're also married right
yeah on our private time you know if we
have the private time when you're an
entrepreneur you just don't get that
but yeah
so was this always in the plan that the
two of you are going to start a company
did you the two of you you know even
when you started you know dating and in
a relationship was it was this sort of
where you were headed to
no but when we met we were extremely
loyal to niltsuk we worked at palo alto
networks um
um but yeah it was a it was a dream for
both of us to to create something um
uh just the two of us right
um
and and when the opportunity
came or created uh we were like all
hands on deck and just let's do this
um
yeah
so i have to hear before we get into the
you know the running company and the
complexities of that the story of
meeting take take me back to then
ah okay you want to share the story i
think that you'll share i'll share this
story
okay
like this yeah um so
we've met at palo alto networks yoni was
one of the first engineers at savera
which was acquired by palo alto networks
and i came right after the acquisition
to lead the recruitment
um
what to get into details i fell in love
with this
awesome man because he's
like beyond perfection seriously
um
now he's embarrassed
yeah okay deal with this um
when we've started dating while it was
like
we're not the kind of couple i don't
really know yeah we don't remember what
happened we don't remember how
i many years
it's
eight maybe never mind
um yeah but we've started dating um and
and to be completely tmi
um back then i had two uh uh kids of my
own nom and no mel um so it was a uh
quite a you know a change or jump
um
with the relationship very very fast
very very soon um
and
since then i'm like i'm waking up on a
daily basis
fall in love so i love it give me that i
love it so yoni tell me you when you
when you if you're together in political
networks
so can you know you're working together
what what makes you realize that there's
an opportunity to not just work together
in a company but actually to build a
company together it's two very different
things
very different you know and there's a
lot of consequences obviously that are
going to be translated to the personal
life so how what what's going through
your mind as as you're starting to talk
about this idea
yeah so i think that
we never really had these kind of doubts
that you you maybe spoke about now
because
i think that
we're
you know maybe i'm also a bit uh
this but like we're a perfect match
right we we're partners in life and
we're partners in everything we can't
really like
imagine life without each other so it's
also like this in the in the business
and actually
we work together at palo alto and then
amid left
and to the competitors
to the sentinel one
uh
and
also then we felt that we want to work
together again and we just waited to to
the opportunity to do this
and i tried to hire him for sentinel one
but it didn't work um
so you said let's just start a company
together
so building the company together was
easy we knew that it's a
giant
venture and we both wanted to do this
and we talked about it a lot and
you know i'm happy that it happened and
i'm happy that it happened like it
it's it's now and
looking forward to the you know
to this to continue more well you're
already on a you know on a crazy journey
and and you have some incredible
partners on board and amazing customers
and
take me taking going back again to the
you know really the beginning pieces of
it how much do you talk about
what this means for you now as as a
couple what this means for the private
life for the home because you know
there's one thing when you're bringing
you know your work home and you're doing
emails it's another thing when you know
your co-founder is at home and a lot of
the conversations i i guess naturally
tend to be about the company
yeah 100 percent like
99 is about complete one percent about
our three uh boys um but the thing is
that
that what uh motivates us right um so we
don't need to fill our lives with um you
know the extra um that's what keeps us
uh awake at night because uh uh we wanna
do more and achieve more and get more
and and and drive the this venture
further more um
and and
we don't see this as okay let's have a
clear cut and clear uh separation
between the private life and when you're
an entrepreneur like you
you're fully in this right um and the
understanding is that
um
that's our life
seriously i think there's a lot of
things it's easier because
everything is aligned right we have the
same goals both personal goals and both
business goals
so it makes it more easier in that
aspect
so what's the best part the really the
best piece of working together as a
couple and obviously you know what the
next question is going to be but but
what is the easiest what is it the the
best part of this
oh
you want to answer that
there are a lot of things it can't
really
i think that you know uh
you always hear about
entrepreneurship and how lonely it is so
i don't think that it's lonely
here right i always have someone that i
know
i can trust and has my back so so it's
really makes the experience a lot better
and
and you know everything like like we
we have
the same like uh
joy from stuff and we can celebrate
together everything and we understand
each other
right when you when we work in other
companies then you know
you achieved something but the other
side was happy for you but it's not the
same here it's completely like
everything is is the same uh
i'm with you
so what's the
hardest part of it what is the biggest
challenge that you're facing
i think to be frankly honest and i know
it will sounds a bit naive or i don't
know
or too good to be true
i think
the hard parts of
being co-founders it's not with my
founder okay with my co-founder it's
about being a co-founder uh in an early
stage startup with all the unknown and
the uncertainty and all those kind of
things right um it's about the talent
war and all those kind of crazy things
but um with the honey it's it's easy um
he's i i think i i shared this with you
when on the last time that we spoke he's
my ink to my young so he's my safe zone
he's
the one i trust the most admire the most
uh he's the one that makes me
laugh like um
so
yeah we disagree from time to time
obviously uh we're not the same person
but everything is
being so
um respectful and and um when you trust
the the person with you um
the hard times are just not hard as
in described
lot of ways it even helps us
like improve the communication right
when you have a business you communicate
a lot more you need to
like i said before when everything is
aligned the person and the business then
we're both aligned and we we need to
keep talking all the time to help each
other you know everyone has their ups
and downs in this journey
and
yeah
it's the easiest when when amit is here
with me in this channel
sounds so
like unreal
it you know it does sound unreal a
little bit better but i i believe it i
mean you can i think just from from both
our previous conversation and and
watching you you work and the things
you're doing i think that there's no way
not to believe it but but no
relationship is perfect and conflicts
arise whether it's as co-founders or
whether it says you know as a couple
how do you make sure that these things
don't mix or or do you let them mix is
there is there a way to avoid that
i must disagree i think that my
relationship with yoni is perfect
seriously um
i
you know i i love
each part of him seriously um i think he
makes me
like he improves me
he brings
my better version out of me um so
yeah of course we disagree from some
from time to time needless to say we're
again we're not the same person but um
he's the one that i admire the most so i
i i consider myself the like the most
fortunate person in in the planet
seriously in terms of this time i'm a
bit uh
[Music]
it's a bit like
that i don't have enough words like i
made to describe everything
you're the city oh
that's why you're the ceo exactly her
job is to find the words
but i just i don't have like the the
same words and to
i can't explain it it's okay your eyes
speak it's okay
so as you're going on the journey did
you have to develop some
rules was this any
at any point in time you know a
worrisome feature for maybe investors
you know talent that's coming saying wow
you know there's like we live in a we we
come to the office the company lives
here but then the company continues
living for another like 12 hours until
we meet amita nyoni back in the office
was there any worry about that or any
discussions that you had to you know
alleviate some of these fears
so before we raise their uh seed now
we're post a
but before we raise the the seed one of
the most famous entrepreneur uh in
israel said to me okay you're a first
time entrepreneur and you're a female
uh and you're in the hr attack and
uh forgot bitten you're
creating this venture with your husband
uh so don't like uh fingers crossed for
you for for the fundraising and to be
frankly honest both in the seed and in
the a
it was
easy to raise
they had zero concerns about uh the
relationship that we have at the end of
the day it's all about
uh a few things about the execution okay
it's about the leadership it's about the
vision it's about the people behind it
um and when you combine everything
together you see that it's bigger than
than the uh
founders uh
husband and wife right um we work
together extremely well if you ask our
people our team um they will say that
they don't feel that we're uh husband
and wife right
um
and and i think that's important for for
the investors to understand that
they understand we run a business and we
care about compete and we care about the
customer experience and the and the
innovation that we bring uh with the
product um and that's that's the kind of
conversation that we're managing and and
not about
the relationship that we have although
open brackets
it's awesome um but
that's that's the conversation that we
have with the investors and they see
that um
incredible
if you have to look at i'm sure there's
so many you know couples in the around
the world that are considering opening a
business together you know at the end of
the day we partner with people who share
similar interests and we have perhaps
similar views on life and the way we
want to live our life but it's really
scary i mean i'm thinking for myself
it's a really scary idea to embark on a
on an adventure like this one with with
a partner because what happens if
something goes wrong what happens if we
fight
what what tips or insights do you have
now
having gone through some of this
experience already and being very
successful at it obviously to a lot of
these you know couples that are
considering it but not really sure what
to do
do you want to answer that it's a tough
question
it is that's the reason i just
did that it's hard for me like to put
myself in the shoes of other people
right i i don't necessarily i know about
our relationships i don't know about
other people's relationship
i think that our relationship is
uh like shared based on trust
and we're fully supported by each other
of each other and we
like every one
of us in
his or her domain right and we know we
don't have ego and everybody knows that
yeah you know we decided early on she's
the ceo she i'm the cto and all the
technical side of the business she
handles all the other parts of the
business right
and and it was very clear that uh we're
just doing this together so
i think that maybe like expectations and
what people want
and they need to set this up up front
if they do this but but it's really hard
to tell because you grow with the
business you change a lot a lot of
change in the last and one half years
like yeah
i saw me turning from like
you know from an entrepreneur and
previously like a hr recruiter and then
manager and
and turned into a ceo right you change a
lot also personally it changes you you
know improves but it changes right
and and so there are situations right i
mean at the end your your partners and
your co-founders but but there are
differences that you know the we're all
aware of between the positions some
positions are more outwards facing more
decision making perhaps strategically
thinking you know long term and some of
them are more internal so you know
technological
real you know infrastructure figuring
out how to support the greater vision of
the company
what happens if there's a disagreement
about a decision that needs to be made
but a decision needs to be made and
usually the ceo ends up making the
decision right
it's very clear the ceo takes the
decision
wow right
now you understand now
in every business it's not
that the fact that we were married
doesn't change the fact that
a company should run like this so so
very clear about the responsibilities
obviously i completely trust them it to
listen to my opinion and if something i
think that's not clear
then you know i'll i'll raise the flag
and tell her
and i'll insist a bit more but
eventually it's the stereo's decision
and uh like like like a shirt there's no
ego here right eventually
she's the ceo she's also accountable
for for this right and i'm accountable
for my part so
no issues
from this
i love it amit same question to you
going looking back you know what are
some things that you think were are
helpful to you
you know obviously there's love and
respect and trust but there's also
tactical things because you're
exchanging you know thousands of
sentences with each other a day you have
to keep this magic going somehow if what
would you tell me if i were to start a
company now with my partner what should
i be what should i be really cognizant
of or intentional about
i think the two key ingredients is to be
bold together and authentic together and
the combination of these two are crucial
for success and for building something
together um
yeah
just building something yeah it's always
to build anything just yeah just yeah
you know as
as married couple we might disagree on
many many things right about the uh
education of for the kids or whatever
it's like endless
um
and and
like any other conversation that we're
having
on our private time or competes time
right
uh the fundamental or the infrastructure
of everything is
respect and and open communication and
and
um when you have that when you wanna
listen to the other side
um
when you truly care about what he's
saying
um
everything is impossible seriously
everything is impossible i love it and
and and last question so just make sure
before that that you're in a
relationship that has that yeah exactly
that's that i think that's the theme
here that the the infrastructure that
the two of you built
you know the trust and respect and
boldness and authenticity allows you to
then translate a lot of these
characteristics to the to the
relationship but but you know the last
last question that i haven't you know
because i truly am curious about this in
you know so you're mentioning that in
you know the company side of of course
at the end the ceo needs to make a
decision and the other parties have to
respect it regardless if it's your you
know if it's your partner or whether
it's just a colleague
but then you know you have similar you
know really big decisions to be making
in in real life and there are the same
you know disagreements in real life
maybe not about business but about
education or about living or whatever
how are you able to differentiate from
okay now it's not ceo cto now it's just
two partners that you know we have to
come up with a consensus at the end we
can't just have one person call the
shots
shall i say that in the
now private time you're the ceo
maybe we're co-ceos right maybe
but not in the business
yeah i don't think that's uh
i really don't think that we have this
kind of issue we
we really we don't we also don't
we don't go into the small details and
like uh fight over uh small things right
we only
if we have disagreements it's only about
big things and you know we work it out
like you do in the business and that's
why that's why i said that it's also
like a better communication in our
personal life because you need to solve
stuff in the business you don't you
don't get to go like uh
to be upset and just take time off you
need to solve it do you have a company
to run you have employees watching right
you need to solve the issues
so
so you just gotta do it
i love it i love it
yoni amit this was so enjoyable i
learned so much i've learned a lot over
you know over all the episodes for the
show but in this episode specifically i
got to
you know and bring together two pieces
that are so complicated and so strange
when put together and all of a sudden
i'm watching the two of you talk about
you know not just the respect and then
love for each other but also the way
that you're you're bringing the same
level of trust and authenticity to your
business and and it's starting to click
why compete is you know doing the the
progress that it's doing and and getting
the the love and the attention and the
respect that it's getting
and so thank you very much for for
joining me today i really appreciate
your your openness and your willingness
to do this and
stay safe and stay healthy next time
face to face next time face to face
definitely not during omicron but next
time face to face no
face to face it was great to meet you
thank you very much take care bye
[Music]